uh was a fun weekend right
was it no i was just nothing's fun
anymore there's no joy in life
even football which is you know it's
nice trust me it's nice to have
it is nice to have but it's not fun
nothing's fun
well it was fun it was fun seeing tom
brady just throw two interceptions still
try to yell at the receivers like it was
their fault
did you see i don't know if you noticed
it was very quick but in the first
quarter of that game
they did a close-up of brady and you
could
watch it sinking in that he's in tampa
bay like you see it in real time he was
like
he looked like he looked like a guy that
took a job he shouldn't have taken like
when you started a job and you go oh no
like what did i get myself into
like i thought this was gonna be great
uh
yeah it was it was funny watching them
it was um
it was funny seeing brady's first drive
was great down the field he ran in for a
touchdown
and then it then he realized oh [ __ ] i
don't have bill belichick anymore
the other thing that was weird was
seeing brady and this is because in how
many preseason games was using that
wrist thing with all the plays you know
like new quarterbacks use a little wrist
uh thing that they have with all the
plays and oh that's seeing somebody
seeing like a veteran like brady doing
that was was
really really funny well i'm a college
football guy now
he's been an autopilot man you've been
in autopilot your entire career
like you know i'm not saying brady's not
good at what he does belichick needed
brady and brady needed belichick but
brady's not like a [ __ ] shot calling
you know i think brady needed belichick
more than belichick needed brady
yeah because he's now going like he you
know he's still habitually going to turn
to bill belichick
before realizing he's not there it's
like somebody who loses their arm
and they still have like a phantom arm
for the longest time
you know brady keeps going what do i
[ __ ] you're not the guy where's the
where's my guy where's my old guy it's
just a bunch of dudes from tampa like
hey
what's up man hey we'll go to 2001 after
this
huh get [ __ ] hammered see some
titties and tom brady's just like
do we try to win games around here dude
i gotta
by the way i got a great guy for molly
for coke
like whatever you need and tom's just
going like what about
the game it was funny seeing jameis
winston he's the backup quarterback for
the saints now
just laughing because he was you know
obviously the starting quarterback
for the bucks um first of all back up
boy
how about you don't laugh at nothing but
you're not a backup
and how about and how about this how
about your drew brees is back up so
guess who's not getting
any game time kiss does not get cause
guess who never gets hurt
and guess who never [ __ ] up drew brees
so you're gonna be sitting you're gonna
be riding that bench
until a shittier team takes you or drew
brees dies and i don't see him dying
anytime soon
i was watching a lot of the games i
think my the game that i like watching
the most i think and i can't believe is
to say this was the bengals games they
should have won the field the
the field goal kicker missed an easy
like 30 yard field goal at the end but
they have that burroughs guy who
was first year out of like lsu that
kid's [ __ ] good
i was watching red zone and by the way
before people who supported the autophil
i'm
i'm watching on illegal streams so i'm
not giving them any money
so let's start with that they get no
money from me and
um they don't get any money for me
either because i always go out to eat
and like watch at a bar so it's on a tv
that it was already gonna be on so i'm
another leech
but anyway i'm a college football guy
college football that was fun to watch
it was yeah i noticed it was a lot more
it felt more like a football game
yeah which was odd to me i wasn't used
to that and not a black lives matter
rally it was very odd to just be like oh
look at this they're playing football
look at that huh oh look at that they're
running a play
i forgot about what that was like yeah
you know who didn't play this weekend
colin kaepernick well i mean unless
you're playing madden
but it was like every time you'd flip to
nfl it was like
we are using our platform as a message
for voices who cannot be heard it was
like every two seconds
and then you just flip the college ball
just pants going [ __ ] people throwing
spirals and you're like
oh look at that football he flipped back
to the nfl
the our nation faces an unprecedented
moment in history
flip back
[Music]
people throw them ball i'm like i guess
college ball is what
is what to watch now plus i always like
the bands anyway
i feel like the nfl really misses out on
a great opportunity here
the other thing i like more about
college football is the [ __ ] bands
the marching bands i don't know why it
just makes it feel like a football game
yeah it feels like more old school
football and you know somebody pointed
out yeah the
the reason the way you watch it's on red
zone because there's no pandering on red
eric
the han hansen guy yeah he doesn't he
just
calls his playstatistic and he only
cares about football i actually had to
for a little bit
watch the because for those that don't
know red zone has two different feeds it
has a hanson feed which is he's the one
that does
if you have cable and you have red zone
he's the one that does that one directv
has this other guy cicero i think is his
name
okay guys sucks he was getting i think
as a new production crew because
he was asking him to pull up games and
they weren't pulling him up right they
were pulling up the wrong graphics like
he was
[ __ ] lit which was which made me want
to watch it more
because he was [ __ ] livid with his
production guys
live it in a professional way like you
know he wasn't but you could tell he was
like
all right we're uh why don't we pull up
the bengals game and he's like
anytime guys the bengals game will be up
in a second i guess
and it was like which when you watch the
hanson feed it's it's
a finely tuned machine um and the and
ciscialano some some guido
does the directv one all right that's
the one who does it
um the one who looks like uh the guy who
took the company the guy do you know
what he looks like the guy on directv
the guy who took the company from walter
white
honestly just like that guy i forget his
name but
the guy who took the company from walter
white that's what he looks like
um it was also weird because with
watching the nfl games
some of the stadiums had fans most of
them didn't
but they were doing the wwe piping crowd
noise in
they weren't allowed to go higher than
75 decibels and at this point no team
has home advantage and that does [ __ ]
make a difference i think like you know
if you're in the [ __ ] dome
and i saw people complaining online
going
can you believe that they're playing a
football game in new orleans
even though in 24 hours we're gonna have
hurricane force winds can you believe
that i'm like yeah i can
i'd understand your point if they were
allowing fans but the only people in
there were like
the camera crew refs and [ __ ] coaches
and football players
also i mean let's calm down it's coming
in a day
i i never you know i saw other you're
right i saw other people doing that too
they were like can you believe this and
i'm like
yeah hurricanes not till tomorrow or the
next day plus they slow down
a lot like historically so why would you
why would you cancel anything
before a thing i don't understand that
because they wanted people to evacuate i
guess but
again the fans weren't allowed in the
stadium so
and nobody's evacuating for that like
look get it through your [ __ ] heads
if you live in louisiana or florida
and certain in certain parts of georgia
we don't leave
we just don't leave like it's they blow
through here all the time and
and i mean you it has to be there has to
be some kind of
cataclysmic loss of life or
infrastructure for people from that area
to either anyone in the gulf coast
they're not leaving so you're telling
people we need to cancel the game
so people can get a head start on
leaving nobody's leaving what is it like
it's a tropical storm right it's not
even a hurricane
uh it's gonna be hurricane i think it's
gonna hurricane force winds they're
saying uh
but i'm i don't know it was a tropical
storm
as of yesterday yeah so shut the [ __ ] up
nobody
in the gulf area is ever going to leave
town over a tropical storm you're never
going to see it
people that live on the beach in florida
go tropical storm it's not a hurricane
though no i'm staying this is [ __ ]
stupid
yeah uh it's it it so we just had a cat
one it was fun
again i think that you know the new
orleans thing i think people it's
because of when the katrina happened and
the levees broke and all that stuff
um people freak out about that but i
mean
if you live down here if you live in
this area i mean florida
you don't really panic even unless it's
like a cat 4
you don't really panic cat 4 is when you
start to go
like okay yeah we should maybe start
looking at a hotel
maybe get inland you know what i do on
cat force because i mean i'm really good
i'm really good at hurricane prep i put
two pieces of masking tape at like an x
over the windows that's perfect and
that's it right solid that'll stop
that'll stop a [ __ ] fire hydrant from
flying through the window
do you know how many people actually do
that mm-hmm that's oh i've seen it
you've been highly
oh i've seen it i i've seen it not even
in hialeah tampa the same thing you'll
always see the little
and you're like what are you doing man
just buy the shutters
yeah seriously buy the shutters or get
the hurricane glass i mean that's it
the funny thing is is when you live in
like the hood in tampa they got legit
bars over the window
like tampa certain parts of ybor city
are the closest thing you'll ever get
to like south central los angeles just
in terms of like
they're the short stubby little cement
buildings with iron bars over the
windows
those people don't do anything because
they have bars over their windows so
we'll be fine we don't own anything good
anyway
like somebody said don't build the city
below sea level look if we applied that
rule then we
don't build a city in the [ __ ] desert
don't build the city in a hurricane
alley
most cities are built where some batches
could happen i mean that's just the fact
of life
yeah and i mean you could technically um
[Music]
be fine if your infrastructure is decent
i mean
the levy's broke because you know the
bob levies nobody gave a [ __ ]
nobody kept up but like you know the
levees broke because
people were like hey you know these are
gonna break right like
you know we built these temporarily like
100 years ago
right you know we were supposed to
replace this with something
and it just they kept reminding you and
kept reminding you and then one day they
collapsed and everybody went
oh my god i guess we should never have
new orleans again it's like well no if
you just heeded their advice and
said look that thing we te it's like
when you get something fixed on a car or
a house and they go look man
i'll get you through the winter okay we
can get this pipe fit
but when the summer comes and you have
more money you're gonna have to take
this as a temporary fix
and you go that'll be fine it's like
when you if when you put fix a flat
in your tire exactly like it'll last a
few days a week maybe even but you're
gonna have to get that tire patched or
fixed
you need to immediately take it
somewhere to get it yeah
and i've known people that have done
that move the old put fix a flat on it
and just keep driving and
you know like it's fixed and mechanics
hate it because then when they take the
tire if it's filled with this goop
and it's yeah it's because it hardened
like yeah it hardens it's on the rim
yeah it's a [ __ ] yeah it's a [ __ ]
show but yeah you know
there are people that'll get fix a flat
and they'll go what it says fixed right
in the can like what do you
it's fixed right